doesn't seem to understand that I don't
I'm not I guess I could be taking away
maybe a hundred like when we watched it
it was about 120 people on and when I
lose by 120 people we're gonna have
words
the but it's definitely been fun fun to
do and the celebrity show off show on
TBS all right so I was thinking of
something before and then I just went
out of my head
how's everybody doing today I forget
that we can't hear them can they hear us
though kids it's my fault yes my fault
all right
tell yourself on the sword right now it
is it is his fault he's trying to try to
pick [ __ ] me and she just [ __ ] games
and [ __ ] watches my show without
making people go to youtube you watch it
all week long and then two minutes four
I get here he's like oh [ __ ] I should
get another Mike why is people saying
remember guys not to be an ass but you
guys could turn up your mic - oh [ __ ]
that's what the audience loves when the
host turns on the audience and says you
know who's [ __ ] up here kids the hype
train is rolling man rolling we have a
limited time to earn exclusive emojis
all right train at 41% with four minutes
and change to go feeling relatively
confident we'll get to at least level
two what do I know though look me in the
mouth maybe I don't know there is an
echo I was trying to see if I open up
another source if it would make it
louder but it just made an echo but I I
went back there saying you're fine it's
neat it glow but we know that that's
because I'm over here you have an echo
there's in real-time they're still
saying it has an echo it goes all good
man J Burl's goddess
all right the maestro
sass just used 1,500 bits shoved him
straight up Jays ass well done my friend
71 percent on the hype train level one
man level one with like four minutes to
go and look at that it just took a big
jump somebody did something what
happened it says here the master of SAS
59 beds Oh donk it was a donkey punch
Diamond has gifted a sub tier 1 sub and
then somebody else gave something Oh poo
fighter JimBob has used 40 bits and that
is getting us to 92% oh my god the hype
train is about to take the [ __ ] off yes
100% I don't know what it means I think
it means I'm walking away with cash and
prizes
who else man Wolfen deity use two
hundred bits eden Martin 30 bits all the
bits are coming this God 83 is gifted a
tier 1 sub strong style King 500 bits
here oh man Jager man yinsen finding out
they're trying to figure out the names
it is it is I mean it feels like 200
bits it feels like corn fox hunter pits
it was like knowing four years of
Spanish Spanish taking Spanish one for
four years really not even Spanish for
and then trying to go to barthelona and
passing like where you're like um metal
Matt Valley Colonel Mustard thanks for
the 10 subs bro Colonel Mustard in the
kitchen with the subs go figure man I'm
the hype train ladies John looks like
it's pulled into the second station are
we already on level three level two is
complete we're at level three oh yeah I
didn't pay attention to it in the height
trains rolling woo
I said woo crept 1c has used 24 bits to
make your life a little [ __ ] better
Polina just Felina 21 bits thank you and
my key finger 30 bits Oh Lord mu B has
used one bit 1 bit Sarah
dee has used 10 bits and the hype train
just rolling kids we have not not gotten
through a hype tram with Kevin here so
come on guys we have in the past not
today this would be the first type train
of the day if we could get to a decent
location we're at level three right now
man DB Murray gave us a hundred bits
dislocated eight gave us 500 big housing
pitch from somebody damn
buh-bah Beck's fat bull Beck's fat said
98 says here's a thousand bits ya piece
of [ __ ] that's what he says to you Wow
the hype train is rolling kids Darren
valkyrion 500 bits and blockhead coming
strong with ten bits I crept one scene
not to be outdone said here's three
[ __ ] bits he says why don't you go
home and get your gear box Jack your
bits box hundred Neil f1 2300 bits Jay
Meister 595 bits welcome to Jay and
Silent Bob get twitchy where we
literally just read the bits allowed but
it's working because 92 percent on level
three of the hype train level three man
that means soon we'll be cruising into
the station heading the level four if
we're lucky
oh the master of SAS has used a thousand
bits may you live to be a thousand years
old master of bits who it is master SAS
Matt I said master bits Matt McClane
Matt Matt Matt 73 gave you a bunch of
who is that where'd you get the tape in
it he gave me ten cents ten sobs
infinity heavens you're so kind
level for pinfinity are just gifted you
ten Tier one subs though he said a sir
yes sir
I'm here to back up the information
co-signed still thrilling to me it's
like being in Vegas just I don't pull
down on any levers and
right this [ __ ] right here twitch in
Jays little man cave is socially distant
Vegas
with the exception of we're awfully
close for the 1500 sir my name is Gavin
says Bobo fax fat 98 and he says yoga
hosers rocked and then he says [ __ ]
critics Thank You Man thank you I mean
not necessarily for bug Greg's but for
saying yo go there rocks
I enjoyed this Kevin Smith get at least
half says Dino three no I don't even
know what if this all means I'm too old
I'm gonna be 50 next month in August
August 2nd man where's my hype train for
my for my 50th year gave you 5 tier 1
subs and said and when people asked who
gave them to you it you say what's a
restless betta this code this code 83 it
looks like said 1500 bits what are the
bits would you explain as the hype train
completes level form we head off to
level 5 level 5 level 5 I like a pack of
like such and such advance for $20 again
1200 gets for like 20 bucks right they
buy it from from twitch and then they
could cheer like one bit 5 those members
and it's just showing like hey man I
like you should serve instant coke says
I watched some in lockdown episode 4
twice already
thank you yes if you're just jumping on
now pop on over to youtube and watch my
little sitcom with J's in it this week
son in lockdown for a celebrity show up
show on TBS J has a t-shirt cannon that
we pack full of hater tots tater tots
and Bob lamb watch the fun in Sue
Smith's movies says radical lizards and
own movies you could watch over and over
somebody's at tusk is their Jam thank
you level 5 hype train kids we're at 7
percent we're gonna get there we're
gettin the station man there's no two
ways about it a reaper
educating on san diego comicon online
here we are well I am I don't know about
you but I did a big panel where we
finished it and sent it in and then the
kind folks at comic-con were like what's
with all the cursing and so we had to go
back and leap out all the curses
apparently I cursed quite a bit
apparently I cuss like a sailor so they
bleeped out all the [ __ ] [ __ ] mother
mother [ __ ] bug and yeah we're gonna be
part of the San Diego comic-con online
but I understand both DC is not DC is
doing the DC fandom ma'am and a minimun
and ma'am and I'm in a minute doing her
own [ __ ] thing and Marvel is also not
going to be a part of the San Diego
comic-con online experience they too
might be doing their own thing which is
smart money like you know Disney might
just do a whole d23 kind of thing and
whatnot but everyone getting proprietary
online this is this is good real estate
right here man to fight some
[ __ ] to get some time on Jays
twitch chat ah I had to fight the good
folks at Lego what else do you do when
I'm not around have you know resorted to
jerking off on Twitch ah that'll get you
thrown off because you can that just
changed recently because remember like
not too long ago we were like let's
watch the movies right here on Twitch
and you can't do that now you can do
that you know why because now the whole
world has moved online and people are
now ones looking for every nickel and
every cent right because you can't make
money the normal way so I'm sure you
know all these media companies that for
years were like oh my god let me use the
movie clips what do I care they're like
wait we can make money off of this now
we gotta pull that back sorry to cut you
off but we have one minute 40 seconds
left guys to get through this last level
that's right one is because of folks
like strolls one who gave us 300 bits
and Megas Vaughn Conti okay that's 25
bits one
and a half to get the level five fish
gave us a hundred bits box thief has
donated we got ten bits coming for power
fist another ten bits from baby weenus
one minute and 15 seconds we might not
make it we took it for granted and now
we're never going to get to the station
a minute left we got to make all make
the man boys dreams come true he just
wants to get to level five - don't
embarrass him in front of his buddy man
100 bits from indie geek 99 from GOG go
and see why game is a Tier one there's a
race against time Vegas all over ladies
gentlemen winner winner vegan dinner yes
thank you guys seriously very very very
very much everybody
what happens now and now we get to live
forever live for a lifetime
boy that was exciting my brother waffle
Bravo waffles goes literally nothing
Trey Marx's vegan dinner sounds like a
loss amen
that be on meat is good if you were
talking about like kumquats or broccoli
I'm with you we like all the [ __ ] that's
like you know we're gonna take something
we're gonna take a vegetable and make it
taste like a of meat that's kind of what
we're into although his lady cook some
real live vegetables don't she like to
like cook em up she's always like if you
ate with you ate him the way I made him
you'd like he's got to say she stands on
the other side of the door like [ __ ]
good about my cauliflower my best my
favorite dinner she makes is a pancetta
cauliflower pancetta pasta and it's
cauliflower pancetta and pasta and
some sauce and stuff like that I'm
getting old man neck soon is I mean I'm
about to be 50 the wrinkles aren't
really there yet your eyes
[ __ ] squinting at your tiny dick you
look in the mirror like is that my dick
and so you got you got dick looking
crow's feet is what he's got um no I
don't think it was from wearing
sunglasses
I think it's cuz I never go out i lurk
in the darkness like [ __ ] Batman or
driver nah that's true man when they
turn on the lights I'm like yeah I don't
have many wrinkles yet man that'll
change why what a rage bread jus some
dark times a lot of bits and coaxes be
on burger is this some kind of fat man
Beyond promo what a lot of people with
what so I just feel like a lot of people
you know because you're quarantined
can't do anything this this dream a lot
of your lip said really nice things
about how the stream helps them get
through the day how nice and they're
1,100 people hanging out with us right
this very [ __ ] second gone what are
we watching what do they do box what do
you guys do that's right we pulled
things out of boxes you're absolutely
correct he ain't lying kids you want to
see some [ __ ] come out of boxes welcome
to another episode of what's in the box
man I am bill and you were about to take
you on an excellent if nots excellent
adventure into some boxes we're gonna
dive deep into some boxes go get that
open box which kind of goes against the
purpose of the show somebody opened it
in my and brought it to my office and
then when I was what's this and I saw
his inside of said no this would be good
for what's in the box so I quickly
closed it up again here it is here can
they see the box I guess which dick out
below
these guys he's working on some [ __ ]
he's handy this was good about this guy
it's like tool time he knows what he's
doing man
he's like Bob Ross and Bob Vila he's
like all to Bob except Silent Bob look
it's from the good folks at mondo do you
know what mondo is Jay mondo is a
cross-platform situation that was
adorable
mondo does all this cool poster art work
they do alternative posters and whatnot
if you ever seen a poster you're like
for a movie you know and you're like
that's [ __ ] cool then it probably
came from mondo they're based in Austin
I believe if I remember correctly Tim
League who owns the Alamo Drafthouse the
great Alamo Drafthouse I believe he is
involved if not flat-out owns mondo and
stuff oh yeah because this comes with a
look a free rental for the alma one free
rental buy an Alamo on demand so you
could go online and read something from
the Alamo Drafthouse is there a separate
light on this camera oh there you go
look at that who knew it only took us a
thousand episodes to figure that
anything uh this says right here we hope
you and your family are staying safe and
healthy now please enjoy this mondo Care
Pack to help pass the time while in
quarantine love your friends at mondo
hash tag my mondo mo n do not to be
confused of mando three bubble-poppin
action look at that look at this give me
that paper that's classy see this is
[ __ ] classy look they've got people
with their name on it how do we get that
how do we get to get some [ __ ] James
on Bob paper
somewhere out there people like ya kill
him or kill some more [ __ ] trees just
to get your stupid face another piece of
what you got show us castlevania
castlevania by Becky Cloonan it is a
puzzle it's a thousand-piece puzzle
Castlevania is also you know a show on
Netflix and that the guys who are
currently the same from I said guys it's
men and women who are currently
animating so I should say people the
good people who are animating our
Masters of the Universe show for Netflix
also animate Castlevania and this is a
Castlevania I think that's just a
coincidence this is a thousand-piece
puzzle who is it are you a puzzle guy
not really that will be giving away for
sure if you're cool with it
yeah listen him he's like [ __ ] puzzles
who wants it so who wants this
Castlevania puzzle are you thousand
pieces that will keep you busy for a
couple days in quarantine
do you love Castlevania show us how much
tell us how much who wins
give me the bubble wraps as Stephen
Hendry I'm with you that shit's so fun
all right pull it out we will do marbles
after if you want to tell it when we're
gonna play marbles we are we're gonna
play coming up later on in the show
marbles oh come up keeping kids
it is a black panther art of soundtracks
what is it I guess it's a Black Panther
album yeah yeah it's the score you go
let me hold it up I mean it's a it's
getting turn that light down for a
second then we can turn it back up maybe
we'll just use the ball yeah I mean it's
an album it's the entire score it looks
like two black panther available now
ant-man from also available ant-man the
wasp Marvel's Luke Cage season 2
available online at
Doty's calm yeah Hollywood Records it's
a record it's a four how many I know
baby
three vinyl set heavy indeed lid big
goranson score look at that man oh my
god they're making albums over there is
there nothing mondo can't do pretty damn
sweet who wants that kids who's a big
enough fan to get that who wants to lay
claim to the Black Panther album let's
see that's pretty much the dog's
bollocks says monkey hollom right there
how about the record what's the actual
record look like says Mike parson I mean
you don't yeah we don't want to open it
right I mean I know it's what's in the
box but it's not what's in the record
album we kind of know it'll be a
surprise when you get it all right whoa
ba-bum ba-bum a ton hold on bobba bobba
nope Bubba and tor Tasha says yay I just
got my covent test back and I was
negative yeah well done man welcome to
the negative zone hibernation exes are
you wearing pants [ __ ] no let's see
records all look pretty much the same on
the inside says CY 76 I think the other
cat was asking probably because it might
have like a picture disc or something
like that but still some are colored
some some have multiple colors and stuff
but still we might like if I was gonna
get that record I mean I'd be happy to
get it free or whatever [ __ ] but like it
was unsealed I'd be like Jay and Silent
Bob touched it they're always touching
it their own dicks yeah what else you
got let's see oh [ __ ] I'm taking it I'm
totally taking this it's a mondo jaws
pin and it's a big girl swimmer and the
shark so you can separate them on either
lapel or put a mourn over the other
stuff this is not per se all night it's
not a program it's going in my pocket
to go what do we got here man unmatched
what is it it is why can't they just
tell you on the Box what things are
artists movie star philosopher dragon
tell your opponent - oh it's a game
tell your opponent - bring it on then
unleash the one-inch punch but remember
always be like water use Bruce Lee's
custom action card deck to emulate his
signature fighting style an indomitable
spirit man contents 1 miniature figure 1
Health aisle and 31 cards man in battle
there are no equals and that was the
quote from my wife
give me that one-inch punch it is a
one-inch punch so it's a game card game
with a little Bruce Lee piece that's
pretty sweet it's pretty cool in this
item but this is really cool I saved the
best somebody asked me about my pin it's
my back Kevin Smith club join that Kevin
Smith Club calm if you can't do it with
bits though what's this holy [ __ ] this
is heavy
video vortex by mondo games [ __ ] [ __ ]
does everything go to mondo calm or
mondo tees calm I don't know if they're
selling this there but they must choose
your mutant prepare for battle guard
your map run time guard your run time
rent your arsenal it is heaviest [ __ ]
game designed by Trevon Haskell and
Mitch Reichman Brickman story by Zach
Carlson I always loved it this story
people get credit now they should write
illustration by bowling face son what
does that look like so there's a timer
ages and players 2 to 4 players but on
the back it looks like there's an actual
electronic piece that you get to pick
your mutant that looks electronica up
glass it feels heavy man
let's take that's actually this game
contains [ __ ] that is some tiny ass
writing you see that it's a decent-size
game board 12 even character sheets very
fancy player boards loads of cards run
time dial tokens Suns a bunch of those
cool acrylic cubes a first player marker
game instructions that read like VCR
instructions the Box you're holding and
the strip of paper you'll give to your
cat jokes that's awesome man but I'll
tell you right now girth
kids and weight you could drop this on
somebody's head not even from like the
top of the Empire State Building and
would probably [ __ ] take their lives
so thank you to mando who put a bunch of
stuff in a box and gave it it gave it
away hoping you know to spread a little
joy and also probably hoping to get a
little attention which is exactly what
we get very nice Thank You mondo and for
those people that want the contents of
the mondo box you know what to do what
do they do so we'll be playing marbles
after marbles guys everyone knows and
marbles you just hit exclamation play
and there is a marble race so that'll be
fun we always do that after Kevin leaves
and then we'll give them away so that'll
be fun you hear me that will be fun
check out one game I don't know we'll
see I was working on Mallrats Twilight
at the mall rat to miry right before I
got here and I was way into it so I'm
probably gonna die back there I might
skip the marble action but that doesn't
mean I don't respect it and I hope
people get that free [ __ ] man and when
you do hashtag what did they say
hashtag my mondo my mo n do all right
what do you got and mondo was his name o
mo ND o mo and Vito mo and Bo and mondo
was its name
oh all right here we go now this is a
box full of stuff who from this is from
TKO
these this is a box of from what I
understand our graphic novels from TKO
studios is that correct yes sir my bang
let's open it up to the good folks at
TKO the seven deadly sins issue zero
through six um look at that that's nice
oh and it's in a nice box here you go
the seven deadly sins
there's your credit your creative team
and it comes with issues zero one two
zero six man I
it's a box literally so there are comics
in the box what a cool idea I don't want
to open it because whoever's gonna get
this probably wants to feel like they
opened it and stuff but pretty damn
sweet I mean should we open at least one
alright [ __ ] it let's open one we're
opening this one kids seven deadly sins
to show you what it looks like inside
because the show after all is called
what is it called the box alright so we
opened up the box and then this was
inside you hold on the box master mirror
and inside we're bound copy single
copies of issues one through six of the
seven deadly sins by TKO studios man
look there's a bunch of them in there
so how sweet is that alright so that's
that's what it looks like inside the box
you like comic books you like readin we
got something for you man
TKO Studios gonna we're gonna send you
the TKO studios seven deadly sins PAC
what do we got next this is Sarah from
TKO studios by Garth Ennis good old
Garth Ennis create a preacher and Steve
Epting with Elizabeth Wright wiser sarah
collects issues zero one through zero
six this is a $30 value one of the
finest works of Garth Ennis career says
mr. Alan Moore from best-selling comics
writer Garth Ennis who does preacher the
boys of course but just coming back to
Amazon Punisher an artist even
dude Captain America the Avengers in
here you read I cast what is it this is
these two paragraphs in the second
terrible winter of the siege of
leningrad seven women's snipers who find
themselves too caught up in the struggle
against the German invader and so on
yes they're deadly as shot is Sarah
whose inner demons may get well yet
prove her undoing but with the enemy in
their front and the agents of Soviet
state lurking in the shadows
how long can any squad survive the
terrifying maelstrom of warm you [ __ ]
selling me man oh [ __ ] Reid there's
some good-looking art about Sarah a lady
sniper there she is
I'm sorry I said ladies and I'm a sniper
first lady second I guess in the
military service I'm not sure how that
goes but I didn't meant no disrespect um
the knife is out kids so let's see what
else is in the box
shall we
Lord movie says sounds like Sarah's got
her own 1-inch punch but um these are
nice the banks by Roxanne gaming Doyle
and Geordi Bellaire da banks this
collects issues one through six of the
TKO studios book the banks from the New
York Times best-selling writer Roxane
gay an artist Ming Doyle who did the
kitchen steal smart and right or wrong
Chicago let me see if I can do this
burger Chicago Southside for 50 years
the women of the bank's family have been
the most oh my god I'm reading such a
like an idiot for 50 years the women of
the banks family have been the most
successful thieves in the city by
following one simple rule get in get
away get paid and never
get greedy but always but when the
youngest banks damn kid banks who has
long turned her back on her family
stumbles upon the heist of a lifetime
the potential windfall may be enough to
bring three generations of Thieves
together for an incredible score and the
chance to avenge a loved one taken too
soon there's a full tale there's a lot
going on this is the back it collects
six issues of the banks in this gorgeous
little slipcase box that's waiting for
you do you like green do you like the
banks sound interesting how do they find
better they gets free stuff from you
we're gonna play marbles after this guys
I'll package some of the gifts together
we do Marvel games and you guys enter
and stick around and we'll have some fun
Marvel's baby
the last maker says what is that on J
shirt not you tell him it says in this
world gone mad we won't spank the monkey
the monkey was van gogh's I remember
writing that line for Jay and Silent Bob
strike back 20 years ago this was is
this one of those Chive sure so it's a
shirt you could get on the Chive we
believe I think no no that's a jar site
definitely on the Amazon site Jay and
Silent Bob Amazon say eve of extinction
Wow check this out by TKO studios
once again sensing a theme here six
issues compiled in this box eve of
extinction explores a world decimated by
a gender divided apocalypse says Gizmodo
it started with the rain the rain
brought something something that started
changing the men in order to reach their
stranded daughter two mothers must
survive the hurricane and the horrors it
is unleashed but can they work together
long enough to save their daughter in a
world where all men had become monsters
it sounds dope
this could easily be a movie or a TV
show there you go man Eve of extinction
for those the other ones oh my gosh Jeff
Lemire under that name wrote sentient
here sentient what is sentient about it
also you guessed it collects issues zero
one two zero six in this handy-dandy
slip case says from Eisner Award winners
Jeff Lemire and Gabriel Walter
welcome to the USS Montgomery when a
separatist attack kills every adult on
board a colony ship in deep space it's
up to Valery the onboard AI artificial
intelligence to help the ship's children
survive but as they are pursued by
dangerous forces can Valerie become more
than what she was programmed to be a
savior to these children there you go
man [ __ ] oh these all sound don't all
right let's see
TKO studio surprise the fearsome dr.
Fang and there is literally no
description on the back suite it's very
sweet it just says collecting issue zero
one two zero six I don't I can't tell
you what the story's about but the art
looks innocent very present this is
pound for pound which is by natalie
shade shadows Andy Belanger and Daniella
Miwa let's see what it says pound for
pound collects you guessed it issue zero
one two zero six that's a good idea
brand new series by some of the most
buzzed-about names in the industry says
The Hollywood Reporter kill the monster
save your sister and fight the dark
underground MMA fighter
Danny Libra fears nothing except for her
recurring blackouts and fractured
memories that obscure a bloody past but
when her sisters kidnapped
Danny must shine a light on the darkness
in her own mind only question is can she
keep her own demons at bay for long
enough to save her sister alright man
superhero stories right there Pam
four-pound cost more than gold
the more you paid long you stay TKO
Studios presents good night paradise and
we're gonna have to figure this one out
ourselves Josh Dysart and Alberto
ponticello she and Julia Julia Julia
Rusco maybe no description on the back
whatsoever just cat walking so we're not
gonna know but TKO has done it again
ladies and gentlemen they put six issues
of a comic book in a box it's kind of
cool for those of us who like comic
books as opposed to a graphic novel or
something like that
still into the collectability what's in
this box last box of the day we're
getting more ting he'll be right here
this one I guess we should have started
with this TKO no I mean just it with
this box instead of that box so it's a
TKO shirt TKO 2019 sketchbook limited
and it's got pieces by everybody I'm
sorry I'm holding it down and people
need to see it and inside you know
sketchbook and there's the fearsome dr.
Fang yeah that looks dope man really
cool bunch of pins TKO I could always
put these with each book each book that
I send out guys you'll get a sticker
you'll get a pen TKO studios kids
there's another pin whose TKO shirt boy
they got a volume of stuff that they put
out and somebody starting a comic book
company in this world
they deserve all the support you can
give them kids it's tough too tough to
sell comics period even if you got
Batman and spider-man real tough to like
just start and they snot only started
they got a whole line of books oh and
these the trade paperbacks
so let's say you're like I want to hold
the single pamphlets or whatever here's
the bank's trade paperback some lovely
art really nice really nice Earth Eve of
extinction remember that one pound and
we sang gorgeous cover sentient and then
this other one of course is the other
box full catalog books there's the good
night
paradise trade paperback and it's got a
description Venice Beach California Sun
surf sex money murder [ __ ] in when
down and out Eddie stumbles upon the
murder the body of a murdered teenager
run away
he vows to bring her killers to justice
his investigation brings him into the
darkest truths of his beachside town
where he finds he may be the only one
who cares enough to solve this murder
man check that out alright then there's
this bad boy the seven deadly sins the
fearsome dr. Fang the great title and of
course Sara we saw the beginning yes
there's some Garth Ennis you can't go
wrong so there you go
TKO we opened up a bunch TKO TKO
goodness you want in on this TKO action
you're gonna [ __ ] have to fire marbles
at each other's faces at high speeds
that's what what I understand you're
gonna battle with marbles whoever
swallows apparently the most marbles
wins the shirt is that how it goes they
do and thank you number sorry numbers
got his video I did my first cameo today
bro
what do you mean the gentleman that
you marry many moons ago oh you did a
cameo yes and then I just said the term
he just came on here and said thank you
you subscribed and said yeah very cool I
did for a couple weeks ago I did a bunch
of cameos and the money we raised we
matched for black lives matter and it
was I'll be honest with you like it was
a very easy experience yeah like cuz you
just sits right there on the screen
you're like hey ba ba ba it's just time
consuming how long was the cameo that
you did it's nice because I do have
twitch here people come see me but I you
know I just get to read the chat but
without the Comic Cons and the comedy
clubs and stuff I don't get to interact
with people and don't get to say Happy
Anniversary happy birthday so I think
cameo is pretty good between my twitch
and cameo I'm here man I'm available to
say what be have some fun
my birthday's coming up his birthday is
past
yeah my birthday is coming up and I
asked him to get me a Nintendo switch
yes switch which they just announced
Donkey Kong Country for so I'd be
playing that like crazy because I just
want to play my game I just want to play
mall broad ain't so I'm Bob Marlboro so
my birthday is less than a month away I
wonder if I'll get the gift I'm hoping
for and that's from him but if you're
out there going what can I get you cab
what can me get you join that Kevin
Smith Club man it's fun watch wake and
bake wake up bake round Kevin Smith Club
go hang out with him on his birthday
Kendra Lass's Kevin Smith I have bone
number one
Wolverine number one spawn number one
and for Daruma 2099 spider-man 2099
Punisher 2099 and 10 out of the 12
amalgamated comics as well as other
comics all in plastics and cardboard
backings well our
is in your dick huge well done you made
me feel small in front of all these
people I used to have all of those man I
bought well did I bone number one I
never had bone number one but I bought
all those comics in real time back when
I was a comic book collector including
all the amalgamated titles man so I
feels you I know what you're saying I
had those not as well I might have him
in a store because I do own a comic book
store
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash Red
Bank New Jersey go to Jay and Silent Bob
dot-com for all sorts of fun prizes and
savings and [ __ ] the by but in any event
if I own the store technically I own
everything in this story so I bet you I
got some of those books still yeah you
know in a court of law they were like do
you own these titles and I was like no I
bought them years ago but I don't own
them anymore
some lawyer be like aha and they produce
you know [ __ ] they exist in the
secret stash and then that's my third
act in law and order and then I wind up
going to jail anyway
yeah the loophole Jay Meister 5 says it
kept good to see you back on the channel
thank you
any chance of a twilight of the mall rat
sneak peek exclusive for all of us mall
rats out of here waiting for the next
Kevin Smith look love you guys thanks
for keeping us all entertained in this
craziness um let me see what did I do
I'm in the second draft right now but
why light for the mall rats and I think
it was about 25 pages left maybe 30
pages left as I go through I've gave it
out to a bunch of people I trust and got
some notes back and stuff like that so I
was a glue it was a good idea
I'm gonna use this and what can I say
Jason Lee came over last week I think I
talked about it and he had some great
suggestions particularly about Willem he
was this like you know Ethan's jacked
like let's lean into that so that's a
Willem Williams joke lines changed a
bunch we Jay and Silent Bob apparently
in the first draft I might have over
written it particularly the Jamie Bob
stuff
i scaled back and it's better not it's
better that kids is suggestion by Jay
Lee and not like he was like too much of
that there's something really [ __ ] J
this J
his thing was like he's gone like he he
felt like I blew past the goal like he
was like you hit it with this and then
you just kept going like you know this
is great you don't need to keep going
and stuff and when I looked at I was
like he's right it's good it's close
like as we were talking about it he's
like it's so weird because it because I
was like well J it's it's not the same
movie and he goes but it literally is
the same move because it does follow the
structure like very much here here's
something nobody knows first time you
see Brody in twilight of the Mallrats
looks exactly like the first time you
see Brody in Mallrats he's sitting there
sleeping and then a hand comes in and
knocks him on the head there's a lot of
that all throughout the movie like a lot
of like oh like for the audience at a be
like holy [ __ ] is all these Mallrats
callbacks but for the characters you
know it would just be like they wouldn't
notice because this happened 25 years
ago and [ __ ]
so anyway yeah it's been it's been
[ __ ] a hoot man I've been enjoying
the hell of it
archenemy 5:12 goes I just swallowed 18
marbles what do I get
slipstream first says I missed the sober
verse eree as someone who got lost
hundred twenty pounds
I know addiction so good on both of you
for overcoming your demons he did
absolutely no lately I've been having
hard time overcoming my demons all I
want to do is eat and not exercise I
don't want to eat necessarily horrible
food like beans and rice and when it's
real beans and rice bender but yeah it's
it's been easy he can overcome as demons
man I'm just a fighting mine let's see
what else we got have you been to the
local comic shop today new comic book
day - have they opened I know the secret
stash is opened in New Jersey yeah we
got to open up I don't
that every comic stories of them but the
ones that are up and I'm a magic golden
apple with us right yeah we didn't shut
down again right like we just shut down
restaurants and stuff yeah they didn't
shut down comic book stores in
California I mean I don't know I thought
everyone was like but I even went to a
restaurant of the day you know and
everything was done that close brother
nothing's done their cases are spiking
stuff like it's nuts we're gonna be in
this we're it's this is the rest of our
lives dude probably this [ __ ] because I
just read an article where they're like
look they're they're gonna find a
vaccine eventually maybe kind of sort of
but there's a world where this is like
the new normal where we have to live
with kovat where you know they can
ameliorate symptoms but those not
necessarily cure it just like there's no
cure for the common cold like you know
everyone's always like technology will
save us technology does a lot but
sometimes you can't do everything for
example cancer still exists right again
yeah the common cold still it cancers a
big one right and but you figure the
common cold they can't figure that out
how the [ __ ] do you think they're gonna
figure out this [ __ ] so they're saying
the article I read was like it'll
probably be we've been living in masks
for a long long time like kind of like
they do in Asia but you know they
usually wear masks for pollution it's
gonna be like that it's it's never going
back to what we're used to is what
they're saying however I wrote an
article heaven when not wasn't them
being like it's hopeless they were just
like just get ready this is kind of the
way it is but then I read a great
article a thread that mark barnard had
put up on Twitter from like some
scientists and doctors where they were
like there's light at the end of the
tunnel they will find a way to
ameliorate the symptoms even if they
can't eradicate Kovach 19 you know
there's lots of promise right now and
the tests they say that they're doing
there was a piece of news that came out
today where over the course of the last
week that said it could be airborne
which means that like right prior to
this they were saying
if you call that projects it and you
know that's why you stay six feet away
and where mess but what they're saying
now to is it could just hang in the air
it could be airborne and if it just
hangs in the air and you walk into a
room where it was just lingering and
you're like even though there's nobody
in direct contact with kovat if you were
in a room that had Koba today and
sometimes it also means if it's airborne
just flow into your window press so
that's got everybody on edge and whatnot
but it's not the articles I read weren't
like we're [ __ ] like very bury
yourself in the dirt like it was just
like look it's it's just we all got to
keep doing what we're doing wash our
hands wear masks socially distance and
because they don't have a cure for this
[ __ ] yet and I read another article
about [ __ ] horrible this diseases
when you get it it was [ __ ] bad bro
like it scared me and I'm a grown-ass
man and don't scare easily and [ __ ] but
like I read this article and I've been
taking this [ __ ] seriously the whole
time and I am trying to make nobody
scared we're just having a conversation
but I've been taking this thing
seriously I wear a mask and blah blah
blah but at the same time I'm like oh
what a chance as we get it and [ __ ] then
my friend caviar Mike got it
like who literally works down the street
from the house and stuff and is one of
the healthiest people I've ever met
strapping like [ __ ] muscular totally
in shape and [ __ ] like that and he said
that like this almost killed him took
him out he said he lost 40 [ __ ] pounds
and this was a dude who had no weight to
lose kids so I saw that and heard that
housing that's [ __ ] frightening then
I read a piece by this guy who was on
CNN who got it a couple of months ago
and then he went away he said his
symptoms like we're on the lower scale
he wasn't like at death's door but he
said he was very weakened and they had
this call from hell then he got clear or
clean now he says the coffee's back and
the fatigue is back but he also said
there was a lasting effect to having it
wasn't as simple as like I had a colon
that went away I'm now I'm fine yeah
this dude says he's been discombobulated
ever since he's klutzy now he says he
says like when he goes for glasses and
knocks him over because he said the
disease
he likened it to a hurricane that comes
into your body and [ __ ] with everything
it remotely touches which is almost
every one of your organs and then even
when it's gone you're left with [ __ ]
lasting damage that you know you don't
notice right away should do busy living
their king so all this is a long way of
saying that like I'm Way over committed
now to stay in the [ __ ] away like I I
don't you know my kid has been telling
me since this all started she's like you
are high risk because you had a heart
attack and [ __ ] and I was like yeah but
I beat the heart attack and by the way
I'm what I read recently I'm like I
can't I couldn't beat this if I got it
so I don't even want to [ __ ] go near
it and [ __ ] I'm I'm being as careful as
I was being I'm being over the cable he
says not wearing a mask while sitting
around hopefully that didn't make people
like nervous or scared or [ __ ] I'm just
sharing some info I read this morning
and it it gave me it gave me pause and
again I wasn't a person that was just
like I don't believe in it I believe in
everything that they tell me I'm
gullible and trusting uh says are you
are urging them hey how do you guys feel
about genius picking up the stanley
universe brand stoked to see more of the
universe in media or think it should
have been with Marvel and Disney Oh Stan
a bunch of Stan characters are genius
picked up a bunch of Stanley Universe
characters but when you think a Stanley
University like Iron Man
[ __ ] spider-man and it's not it's
other characters he created later on in
life and stuff viable as well and then
his name still absolutely will forever
mean something but he the question by
are Ari's bargman yes should Marvel have
been like we'll buy it the plugin that
would have been nice but they didn't so
I'm just glad that somebody did and
keeps his name out there
Steven Hendricks 123 says Kovac goes
away with time and caution like you're I
think everything in life goes away with
time and caution I guess but I don't
know if it goes away like
and then doesn't ever come back and what
I understand is the shits in waves and
we're still in the first way but let's
not get bogged down on Coben oh [ __ ]
that's long go points out I had kovat 19
and it's bad you seriously do not want
it I was out for two weeks and dropped
15 pounds in ten days and still feel
weak and exhausted my brother-in-law has
it again and he is all messed up from it
okay don't scare you what do you mean
how did he get it again so he had it so
some people feel like well if I have it
once I have it then it's all good but it
can come back they're finding Oh once
you get it you're immune for a while but
no apparently not
um I can't train Laxus I can't think of
a better person to get Kovac from the
Jay Mewes yes how ironic with that yeah
listen this IRA Blankenship says nothing
scares me anymore
fuckin'-a that's the way to be I wish I
could be that person man I'm terrified
everything okay yeah IRA Blankenship
because I was like that scares me he
says nothing scares me anymore that's
the way I want to live and I want to
live that way goddamn it Bonin Easter
says no Stanley has his own company for
a while those characters yes as we were
talking about those characters from
Stan's other company Wow and other than
ventures and stuff just not it was
created years after he was even done at
Marvel consider a Harold Kumar crossover
with Jay and Bob Harold and Kumar tried
to do that in Jay and Silent Bob reboot
but could not get a commitment from
schedule who was it
what are their names in real life
well John chose it and then baby scroll
down people are playing it out of the
ketchup little chair yeah good point
somebody help me out man
might the bottom of the chat Cowpen cow
was talking to Jordan
you know mrs. I was gonna said mrs.
Jason Mewes but really misses he's mrs.
Jordan Monsanto himself and and he was
like oh I can make time for this he was
kind of he was he wasn't like in but he
was just like interested and could make
time and then from what I remembered
like we couldn't reach Jon or something
so at that point the bit fell apart but
eventually morphed into if you've ever
seen Jay and Silent Bob reboot the
method and read scene because method and
read were also it was a scene that had
everybody all the movie stoners and they
all lived in the hollywood h and partied
and stuff and Jay and Silent Bob went to
them for advice in the dream sequence
and then instead it became meppen read
instead and I just did the direct how
high kind of crossover thing and then
Tommy Chang who had said yes to the
other version of scene came and played
our our Alfred our Booker in the blunt
cave sequence so you know it it all
worked out but there was originally a
scene where it was like every cinematic
stoner still alive yeah I was reaching
like yeah [ __ ] we can get this done
and we couldn't but we got enough cool
people to do it very cool people um what
are my thoughts on Halloween kills tree
fitty 777 getting pushed until 2021 is
that what they've said today so it's not
gonna come out in October of 2020 but
October 2021 wow that's a big Bush
that's how you know the world has
changed man like everybody's pulling
their movies and [ __ ] like right now you
know they keep moving Wonder Woman and
you know they I don't think they've
announced a second date for Black Widow
but you know a lot of people are like
starting the movies and you know then
also in like way no no not movies yet
like tenets like [ __ ] Chris Nolan's
new movie that's the
he's supposed to save the movie business
and stuff the movie that's mask worthy
that everyone will make everyone want to
go out to the movies and risk covert
porn stuff but they moved their date a
couple times as well so yeah they
apparently I didn't know this but they
moved how the new Halloween movie of
full over a year so that means somebody
in a position of power at a studio or
jason blum which the same thing one
house guy knows something that we don't
meaning like not like this is a
conspiracy but knows that like oh
nobody's going to the movies in
September or October so we're gonna hold
this [ __ ] a year so anybody like I was
talking to Ernie about spod Castle we've
built Smaug Castle in New Jersey at the
quick stop building little podcast
theater that we were supposed to open up
on 4/20 then we were like alright we'll
open up on July 20th because that's like
the 10-year anniversary of the original
spot castle and then you know the other
day I talked to her knee is like I don't
think we're getting in there until
October I mean we can get in there but I
don't think we can let people in till
October he's saying till the fall so
yeah it's I guess that makes sense man I
mean you want to know something [ __ ]
hysterical they said it on the show last
night but it's true son in lockdown is
literally the only sitcom shooting in
Hollywood right now yeah we are the only
game in town man when there's no other
shows to watch his son in lockdown
speaking of which go to youtube right
now seven hundred seventeen hundred
people do me a favor open your other
screen go to youtube and go to the TBS
channel and click on my short son and
lock them and I need all the hits I can
get so we could stay alive going guys
keep it going
um okay Mike Sparrow 87 says excited for
Ghostbusters [ __ ] yes but I are we gonna
get it cuz if we're not getting
Halloween until 2021 what else are we
gonna get man what else are we not gonna
get avoid the noid says go
[ __ ] up the MCU I mean it's honestly
the first thing that's given it [ __ ]
pause right the only thing that can the
only thing that could stop it thank God
they took the top box off a spot before
the whole world shut down thank God
thank the Lord I mean it's a good thing
they did because it's gonna be a while
before apparently they get to bend their
wares again but you're right man yeah
absolutely right
[ __ ] Thanos couldn't stop the MCU
koba did covin stronger than Thanos
let's treat it seriously ah blastin
zombies 203 says you were awesome on
Celebrity show up last night thank you
oh my god how sweet are you um let's see
the planet trouble diamond says the
planet isn't ready to just muscle
through something like KO but to be
honest yeah um well fingers crossed and
just all do our best Jay Mewes ranked
Annette rank rank one app says have you
already done all the casting for
twilight of the Mallrats
if not is a place stalkers can go apply
to see if we have what it takes yeah
believe me we're gonna need people for
from all rats extras and there'll be
socially distanced I assure you you know
there's there was a school of thought a
few months ago in this town where people
were like are they gonna you know do you
include kovat in your storytelling right
like the idea is like do you do another
draft of twilight of the mall rats
to be fair I had kovin in the first
draft of Twilight at the mall rat a lot
of people are asking though do you wanna
lean into that because you know this
could all go away but I don't I think
this is what the world looks like for a
while and I think even if they do come
up with a vaccine I you know it's not
like they vaccinate everybody in a
[ __ ] day and life goes back to looking
like it did and you know [ __ ] January
or some such [ __ ] so you're gonna see
masks out there in the world why not
reflect that in the movie I don't think
that you know some people were worried
that well that's going to date it I'm
like
we are dated now the whole world is
dated we know what that date is man it
was when [ __ ] Cove it happens so
you're gonna see the effects of this for
quite some time I'm not I'm no scientist
but like and I I don't mean that it's
always gonna be with us but there are
gonna be people that are gonna be
terrified to not go out and masks
anymore so you know it's well and people
that don't want to I get touchy with
people my relatives I saw some article
yesterday going like when are we allowed
to hug our parents again I was like
that's so damn sad but it's true that's
how you gotta treat this [ __ ]
um so I'm long story short I go beds in
my movie like you got to address it and
the after-effects and then you're and
and we're trying to predict you know
what the future will look like in a
[ __ ] Mallrats movie you know what I'm
saying like there are people out there
with numbers statistics models trying to
see what the world is gonna look like
you know six months a year from now I'm
just the [ __ ] I'm Silent Bob and I'm
like well this is what I think the
world's gonna look like in a couple
months or in a year or in any two years
when this movie comes out whenever the
[ __ ] so yeah what a weird ton and but i
i'd start acknowledging the fact that
this [ __ ] ain't that this is not like oh
remember that happened like you know it
seems to be making a greater impact and
unlike some of the other like you know
stars they were able to chase away and
stuff and keep contained this not so
much so fingers crossed
jamie is why Bonin ISTA why don't they
do pay per view from movie theater
prices and release the 20/20 films on
their own pay-per-view channels I'm with
you on that of course but here's the
straight economics of it all let's say
you got a Black Widow now let's say they
you know you buy a brand new movie on
iTunes streaming or whatever it's safe
twenty thirty bucks let's say thirty
let's say we all want Black Widow so
much that we'd be willing to pay $100 to
not own it just watch it once and think
about it you can get a roomful of people
mayhem our old family we can put
everyone together in one room and so you
could have 20 people watching black
Widow for the cost of a hundred bucks
but is one-time only rental right the
furniture it's just once the rental is
done 24 hours later it's gone even if
you did that charge people a hundred
bucks you're not gonna make as much
money straight liquid [ __ ] cash as
you do at the box office man why do you
think they keep making these [ __ ]
movies like all [ __ ] movies because
it's it's a like buying a lottery ticket
but a little more rigged in favor of the
studio the idea is like you pay this
much and if you get it right you are
literally printing money or backing a
[ __ ] truck up and just pulling away
with vast amounts of cash now that is
never once happened to me in my career
my swings by Marvel movies Pixar movies
you know the [ __ ] The Joker
DC movies like Wonder Woman that work
and stuff these movies are printing
money man because each ticket right now
let's call average of 15 to 20 bucks at
a movie theater right and sometimes you
got a movie everybody gotta go see which
like a Marvel movie big you know let's
say moving here let's say a movie costs
100 million to make let's say it costs
200 million to make a lot of these
Marvel movies make a billion dollars and
that's at the box office that's not even
including like hey man we sold a bunch
of infinity gauntlets made of plastic
that make noises and [ __ ] not including
merchandising toy money [ __ ] shirt
money and cereal money and all the
ancillary zand stuff like that
starting including worldwide [ __ ] box
office in some cases sometimes we're
just talking about domestic figures it's
crazy man how much money they make at
the box office and to give that all they
don't want to give it up that's simple
they're like you know I get it
we're fighting Cobin and maybe years
before people get to go to the theaters
again but like we can't this is they're
thinking again that mine is what I
assume from what I've read because I
know about what you do ah
their thinking is just like [ __ ] knows
we'll hold on I mean you just saw it
with Jason Blum and Halloween it's a
Halloween movie it's not even like a
Marvel movie and I'm not saying [ __ ]
Halloween I love John Carpenter and
stuff and I know that last Halloween
movie did well but if
Jason Blum and Blum House are like we're
gonna hold our [ __ ] treasurer for a
[ __ ] year year kids what makes you
think Marvel would ever do anything
different or Disney oh my god bill don't
put that [ __ ] in the vault
until you know they know that they can
just rake in a billion dollars and think
about it if we ever get the free and
clear if they're ever like we've cured
this [ __ ] oh my god you know how people
are gonna celebrate they're gonna want
to do a bunch of things including go to
the movies and sit around a bunch of
people in a packed theater and [ __ ]
watch a movie so I think they're gonna
hold on to it till then I don't I think
we'd have to be in a five-year
quarantine before Disney would start
being like yeah maybe we should think
about letting it go you know it's it's
just that's their business model and you
know the whole world has changed and it
should be changing everyone's business
model but some people are still holding
out hope that ship will ever look like
it did once upon a time but I just don't
know that's the case I'll say right now
I mean I'm [ __ ] me an outlier I'm
sure but lower and outlyer without Lear
and he said but I'd be willing to pay
$200 to watch Black Widow what about you
I would pay $5 towards your 200 to watch
at your home you wouldn't even aunty
come watch it for free in my house but I
mean let's say we weren't we didn't live
close and [ __ ] would you pay well I mean
and this don't count like cuz you're a
what
this is not saying would your life what
would your wife let you pay because we
know the answer is no but let's say that
you were in charge and you could pick
what movies you get to buy would you
spend $200 to see Black Widow you can
watch it like three times or utilize as
many times you can in 24 hours same way
you buy streaming movies or you know
just be a long time before you do now
mind you once they start streaming I'm
sure there's a pirate site to fix it
right back up
good man is a true MEC a Real American
Hero
he won't steal the Plex yeah man I see
just an informal poll kids how many of
you would pay or we could do an actual
poll a vote
hey trademark can you put a poll up with
that yeah I'm curious how many people
would pay $200 let's not be ridiculous
let's go $100 $100 for a 48-hour viewing
window of Black Widow you can't record
it unless you're like a high-tech genius
and some [ __ ] like mr. robot you but you
know basically it's just same way you
rented like any other movie like people
rented The Invisible Man when the
quarantine began it should be like
people the same way you rented trolls
now I'm speaking the language everyone
understands everyone who that trolls did
well same way you went and rented trolls
but it costs you instead of 25 or 30
bucks $100 are we doing the kids whose
bite who wants Black Widow do I hear
$100 hundred Allah no no no your honor
doing it out here do what I do
Netflix is going all right here we go
there's a pull-up kids would you pay
$100 for Black Widow yeah Wow look at
that
I'm pirating it is the number one I
guess this is probably not the forum to
asking them because people like we are
Lords of the Internet why would we pay
for anything
see there's there it is Bonin ista this
is exactly what Disney's afraid oh look
at that 47 people said the hell yeah I'd
pay $100 see Black Widow and 186 people
are like I'm I'm pirating it so that's
probably why they're not going to try
and like they just released Artemis Fowl
which was a big-budget movie directed by
Kenneth Branagh and they released that
on Disney Plus
and they released Hamilton which could
have been a big [ __ ] moneymaker at the
box office and probably will be when
they do a different version that's not
the film the Broadway version let's
still get another bite at that Apple but
you know I would have I would have said
and based on Disney Plus subscriptions I
read one up like something ridiculous
like 25 50 percent on the IPO but I mean
because of Hamilton there were a bunch
of people that subscribed weird LR
downloaded the app for the first time or
whatever the [ __ ] which is an indicator
that like hey I'll try this [ __ ] out so
you know I just can't see them doing it
with their Marvel stuff what do I put in
a driveway drive in building up driving
well it's funny you should say that I
just read an article two days three days
ago about how Walmart is making a deal
in converting like 25% of their parking
lots into drive-in movie theatres
[ __ ] smart right now I know a lot of
people are like can we convert those
parking lots into kovat testing centers
that would probably be better make a lot
more sense but let's be honest that
sounds kind of dope going to watch a
movie in am are in a big ol Walmart
parking lot [ __ ] you can walk into
Walmart get any food you want you can
eat cereal in your [ __ ] car you be
lucky charms watching Black Widow in the
parking lot to play him all my toys you
buy some toys and people who own motor
homes and people who own buses have
known this secret for a long time the
Walmart parking lot gonna get a lot done
in the Walmart parking lot so I would
all right so now here you go Walmart
parking lots because they got Walmart's
everywhere right so that means wherever
there's a Walmart there's a [ __ ] if I
was a movie theater
I'd be going outside with my [ __ ]
screening so they all got big theater
and big parking lots to AMC call me so
if I if I if you're going to Walmart to
watch a movie how much he pain drive-in
at Walmart 250 boxed abdomen for what
the car per person no I pull him at the
car not the first oh I don't know 50
bucks per person in a bad price
it's not a bad price yeah cuz I might
drive and go by myself because they got
it they're only gonna be limited amounts
of space right but you can't fit as many
people you don't have as many screens so
yeah there's gonna be a blight or demand
so 50 bucks a head yeah
which means you can have a car for like
four people and that's 200 hours right
there yeah good truck pickup with Justin
I think we're onto something I guarantee
you did that you still wouldn't even
come remotely close to the money they
used to be able to make just at the
theaters but this is a question now look
at this [ __ ] I'm pirating it one dude
two hundred and seventy nine percent of
the vote only 21% or like me said that
don't plug it hahaha don't ask this
would the new poll is this who did this
trade mark yeah would you pay a hundred
bucks to see Mallrats
- yes are you liars odds a movie worth
pirating you guys see a Marvel movie in
the theaters and [ __ ] on a big screen
has the door eyes Kelso zero says mr.
robot is a go thank you for that I mean
I agree I'm just happy that I pulled
that reference I felt pretty good for
making that mr. robot reference um
where's it of nods it says [ __ ] no it's
just a movie drunken wookies is 50 tops
wicked crispy says I'm poor bargain bin
at Walmart is my budget oh [ __ ] you can
go to Walmart and watch a movie then you
go inside Walmart and buy a movie and
watch it while you're watching a movie
birds one stone
um that wasn't dollar suit Harlequin
8520 says then said just kidding just
kidding maybe I was this matte West
balances I heard a room in a matte
westbound's been cast in twilight of the
Mallrats can you confirm Naing a man
[ __ ] worried until that [ __ ] you
show up you'll be there you ask this mod
squad for evan 6 and that you were in
[ __ ] reboot how are you not going to
be in Mallrats
what does it say Trey Mach says it's all
you [ __ ] with fire sticks is the reason
we can't have nice
things Wow what time is it it's 4:20 oh
holy [ __ ]
kids Minnie Minnie Minnie Minnie Minnie
Minnie Minnie Minnie
welcome to Kevin J talk box office and
mind you we're talking about um he and
talking at all
I'm talking about my ass I don't know
anybody over there and I'm not smart and
successful like those Marvel people but
now you know I I do read a lot and it
seems like the common consensus is they
just they're like why would we ever do
that because money to be made but that
was at the beginning of this every day
we get deeper into this the world
becomes a different place I know the
only thing you can count on Sun and lock
down on celebrity show up on TBS go to
youtube right now and watch my celebrity
of my celebrity show down short son and
lock down those wars episode 1 2 3 & 4
keep removing episode 4 well we don't
care about the other ones about that
weekly competition episode 4 click it as
many times as you can
let's and watch it it's fun our drive in
here has three screens and it's always
sold out to capacity so suicidal failure
Elm I mean of course like that makes
absolute sense where do you live yeah
where the [ __ ] do you have three
drive-in screens what kind of magical
world do you live in where I want to go
live there too
we live in Hell suicide in southern
Colorado our driving is always packed at
three screens southern Colorado hold on
so that's like where we go do the shows
remember we do a Colorado tour we do
like couple of Christmases in a row
Colorado is a big state folks and so
once it when we legal we tour it a lot
so what is the one is a Durango that's
down south is that Bob Durango are you
talking about Durango suicidal failure
town or whatever listen to me I'm trying
to figure out I'm like I've been to
composers it's like Oh
nollans although heaven new orleans
kevin smith crazy thought ever thought
the farthest degree of separation you
are to the cast of galaxy quest + would
you write the sequel movie i mean we're
we're one person removed it goes alan
rickman das thank God Alan Rickman was
amazing the viewer fan of Alan Rickman
and you were like man I hope he was cool
I'm happy to report he was the [ __ ]
best he was so cool he was so lovely one
of my favorite memories I've talked
about it a bunch man - Jesus came a
whole glass of gin that was a Jim that
was [ __ ] seltzer water I can't handle
liquor
look at me I'm saw but J on the set of
Dogma I was setting up a shot and then I
was like remove craft service get some
free food and I walked past and on the
steps of the church from Dogma there is
J sitting next to Alan Rickman and they
are conversing deeply like deeply
engaged blah blah blah blah talking to
one another and all I could think was
like what the [ __ ] could these two
possibly have to say to one another and
a lot he loved [ __ ] newsmen he though
he was so fun um so yeah it is crazy how
close we are to the folks from to the
two galaxies quest one guy removed I got
to speak to the director for the Bill
and Ted panel Bill and Ted's that paced
the music for the comic-con panel so
Dean was the director I believe his name
is and I got to speak to him really nice
guy he'd made Galaxy Quest wonderful
movie oh wow says dirty dirt fits crowd
at all crowded as [ __ ] up in here is it
we're up to almost 1,900 viewers live
ladies and gentlemen watching Jay muses
Channel going who are these two old
[ __ ] you know what I realized you and
me we're dead we're way outside the
demographic they're smart to be doing
this man so kids go like oh I know that
old man he plays video games on my
Internet's yeah man we're we're we're
old news it's a miracle that we could
still ring any interest out of the [ __ ]
we do because we've been around for
twenty six [ __ ] years bro they've seen
every trick we could possibly do so
it's nice thank you for almost 1900
people hang up way blow they said boy
blow Colorado would it be near Pueblo
Durango is is up apparently what's at
the bottom where did we go that was at
the bottom in any event San Jose
California says Curto California crudo
yes San Jose California drive-in has
four screens Arizona 420 radio gaming
says Arizona has a drive-in nine screens
in Texas what we should do is buy some
property a big old empty piece of land
put up a giant screen get to work
giant sound Bob's Drive in Paradise
drive-in makeout brothel Bob's movies -
yeah Jay and Silent Bob go to the movies
we should man in Ennis Texas there's a
drive-in with like ten screens they
always show double features where have
they all been I always thought there was
like five left I thought they were like
the dodo bird people like dodo bird yo
they just used that for like a flea
market yeah Benson coke says who do you
guys think should replace Stanley cameos
he says I'd like Marvel just to throw in
random comic artists writers every movie
I'll be honest with you if nobody should
replaced and that was a beautiful thing
it's absolutely true there's beautiful
thing while I was around and what a
higher honor but if it's just they start
giving it to everybody you know that'll
make them different forever people would
be like remember when they used to do
that Stan cameo hopefully they don't use
it as a demarcation mark in the movies
where they're like those movie starts
sucking once they didn't have the Stan
cameo anymore they got a bunch of new
[ __ ] new phases gonna begin I feel
people's like impatience man I wanted me
some Black Widow I want me some maternal
like I wanna want that story keep going
that's my [ __ ] stories although I did
watch rewatch infinity war the other
morning yesterday morning while I was
signing [ __ ] it is so [ __ ] wonderful
one of the greatest moments I ever had
in the movie theater was I went to a
press screening in New York of infinity
where drag
with me and chip and spoilers if you
haven't seen when Tony gets [ __ ]
stabbed I like I screamed out loud
uncovered mic I was like no and I was on
Twitter the other day and somebody I saw
like ask somebody was your favorite
moment in the movie theater was your
most memorable moment a movie there and
somebody wrote I heard Kevin Smith
scream at the top of his lungs when Tony
Stark got stabbed infinity where I guess
they were at that screening rest of
peace on Rickman hell yeah you ain't can
bethe longus is Warwick New York has
three screens and those double features
you and me like I thought we lived in a
cool place Rambo alien of doom says
Kevin I listen to the very first episode
of vegan abattoir last week and you and
your special new and especially Harley
convinced me to go vegetarian only
vegetarian because I love eggs so much
so far I don't really miss me to be
honest well done I'm not out here to
convince to recruit anybody but I'm just
glad you listen to vegan abattoir if you
want to listen to a podcast where I talk
to my kid it's actually kind of cute and
we talk about we talk about veganism but
you know we don't try to flip anybody -
it's called vegan abattoir because we
slaughter misinformation and put your
[ __ ] and it's on anywhere you can
get a podcast man iTunes SModcast com
free is [ __ ] alright 1900 grew up at
1900 now boy
Trey Mac says our drive in is showing
old movies this month it's Goonies
gremlins and Star Wars The Empire
Strikes Back and they're from what I
understand they're selling out there's
two like ghostbusters I think was the
number one movie last week like people
are like we don't live in a simulation
yes we do and the simulation is just
like let's see what would happen if
Ghostbusters was suddenly a number one
movie in America uh Jeb's TV 27 says
Kevin my fiancee finally admitted to me
she fancies you after watching comic
book men could you give her a shout-out
just to embarrass her her name is
Rihanna Rihanna
[Music]
I'd like to offer you my umbrella um
alright I should turn the show back over
to muse man give it to mr. Jason Mewes
it's his show and I've come in and
commandeered it it's all great I knew
heaven tell Jay he needs a pop filter
enjoyed your movies since my mom
introduced me mall rats when I was 8
cheers guys you're the bestest to be
fair he has a pop filter I took it off
though because I like to work condom off
on my mic let me know nothing to protect
the popping of pennies man uh raw dog
this Mike 9 he's just gotten away and
[ __ ] um
jain's I'm Bob me Billings dad [ __ ] I
wish a movie makes so much money what in
the cemetery we're standing at their
graves and then people are like look at
those dead guys and you're like I know
right they're like we were talking about
you oh all right we only have three in
Minnesota's Mecca jerr-bear 97 bring
drive in to Florida
so skater fantasy they don't have them
there they got lots of flat lands and
they got lots of parking they got a lot
of Walmart's out there they better have
some drive-ins out Florida but like
Disney bought up all property built a
themed barn they love it they paved
paradise there's roughly 1,800 drive-ins
in the US Isis JP 48 69 that's [ __ ]
useful information and I like that kind
of [ __ ] thank you how many 1800 remember
that kid 1,800 1,800
I'm gonna go home tell my wife do you
know there's like 3,000 drive-ins the
numbers just get bigger uh do you have a
good time hanging out getting twitchy
with Jay and Silent Bob James silly Bob
in the hizzy
please continue coming will you do this
every day right I got a schedule can you
guys pop the schedule up somebody pop
that schedule Asian John cyberpunks
everyone's I'm here for Jay and Silent
Bob get twitchy cyberpunks 20 there mm
said rest in peace Hollywood 2020
kid man you are not kidding um yeah man
they making any sitcoms here in town
except Sun in lockdown
starring Jay and Silent Bob kind of Jays
in the new one it's very very funny um
go check it out on YouTube right now the
more clicks I get the better chance I
got is sticking around please don't let
me lose he sticks around and hopefully
we're gonna we're gonna move over
there's something else I got an idea for
you losing lockdown baby you know some
amuse yeah Jay and Tony
it takes us like maybe we got down with
science maybe like five six hours to
shoot the whole thing so even if it's
all over and it's done we shouldn't do
it just keep doing it it's fun it's good
times Ben we're gonna make keep it going
the porthole says sauna Bob when I see
you lose weight I figured if a badass
like you can do it please then so can i
that is absolutely true I lost most of
it but I think by laughing from you both
both your videos thank you oh sweet man
this is why I come here not because he
asked me to because I feel good when I
leave like when I read [ __ ] like Sarah
sheikah says my oh my it's super mega
awesome ultra guy from from the Netflix
show story Bosna wicked pissah says keV
I used to work for an art school and I
had your quote about how it cost nothing
to encourage an artist up on my wall so
many students and parents saw those
words and commented on how beautiful and
inspirational their you did good things
man you are gonna [ __ ] make me cry
are you serious like I wanna go back in
time and tell [ __ ] young Kevin Smith
like the school-age Kevin Smith like one
day they're gonna write some [ __ ] you
say up on a wall in school and some
people will take some [ __ ] comfort in
it and maybe that means a lot thank you
I'm glad I stuck my on to see that um
good to know well there it is man uh-uh
he ain't going away what are you gonna
keep dumb so I'll be here guys for
another another 90 minutes and I'll be
giving away some of these sweet items we
opened in the box we'll play some
marbles
Thank You the good folks at TKO for all
those
books thank you for the good folks at
mondo for their free box of [ __ ] hey do
you have [ __ ] that you'd like to see is
open send us a box just don't let it be
ticking don't put no heads in it please
we get so many of those there it is
folks I'm gonna get out of here go back
and finish my redraft of Twilight of the
mall rats gonna have their 50% less
vultures in it and I'm gonna walk your
mouth everybody as I always do cuz I
need help getting out from an old man
and I'm scared of the 12-foot walk to my
car
so thanks God that's what a good friend
does for you find a friend who'll walk
you to your car
like yours white for heaven's sakes
because I practically am thank you for
hanging out ladies and gentlemen if
you're looking for me you all know me
you know what I do for a living if
you're looking for me go to that Kevin
Smith club.com and join us behind the
enemy lines for good times with
wake-and-bake and [ __ ] like that and oh
my god I'm happening there and I'm here
this is what the show looks like and
don't forget summon lockdown go watch it
on YouTube give me them clicks I need
your clicks now I'm gonna go walk out to
my car thank God I have an escort see
you next week kids
you